und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend russland hat begonnen in den
besetzten ukrainischen Gebieten
scheinreferenten durchzuführen ein
durchsichtiges Manöver aber um
internationale Anerkennung geht es dem
Kreml und sein Kollaborateuren dabei ja
auch nicht viel mehr dient dass der
Propaganda nach innen um der russischen
Bevölkerung die heimische Mobilmachung
zu begründen mit den immer gleichen
Slogans Russen in Gefahr Nazis am Werk
der Westen attackiert uns und sobald die
besetzten Gebiete angeblich beigetreten
sind wird man dann auch noch behaupten
dass russisches Staatsgebiet angegriffen
wird Nina liebergall Berichte
so sieht sie aus die angeblich freie
Abstimmung in den von Russland besetzten
Gebieten
wir sind wegen des Referendums hier
bitte öffnen Sie die Tür
in Donezk ziehen Wahlhelferinnen von
Haus zu Haus auf dem Wahlzettel nur eine
Frage sind sie dafür sich der Russischen
Föderation anzuschließen dieser Anwohner
erklärt vor laufender Kamera wieso er
sein Kreuz bei Jahr machen wird
es ist wichtig wir haben uns schon
gefragt wann wir Russland beitreten
werden unser Leben wird entspannter sein
den Zettel wirft er in eine
durchsichtige Box unter den Augen der
bahnhelferinnen geheim ist anders
die sogenannten Referentin medienwirksam
inszeniert etwa die Auftritte Kreml
treuer Politiker wie Denise puschilin
von Moskau eingesetzt als Anführer der
selbsternannten Volksrepublik durniersk
ich werde zuversichtlicher dass das
wofür wir so lange gekämpft haben
Wirklichkeit wird dass wir heimkehren
in diesen vier Regionen sind laut
russischen Medien über 3,5 Millionen
Menschen aufgerufen ihre Stimme
abzugeben bis Dienstag haben Sie Zeit
fest installierte Wahllokale gibt es
noch keine wegen der Angst vor
ukrainischen Angriffen heißt es mobile
Urnen werden daher ohne Vorankündigung
aufgebaut wie hier in einem Hinterhof
von Mario Pohl der Kreml kündigt eine
rasche Annexion an auf die Frage eines
Reporters ob Angriffe auf besetzte
Gebiete danach als Angriffe auf
russisches Territorium gewertet werden
antwortet Putin Sprecher Peskow
natürlich die Verfassung der Russischen
Föderation wird in Bezug auf diese
Gebiete sofort in Kraft treten
in Moskau feiern sie schon mal das
erwünschte Ergebnis
vorzeigepatrioten singen über einen
ruhmreiches Russland und liefern die
Bilder die Putin jetzt braucht Russland
das geschlossen hinter ihm zu stehen
scheint
dabei geht in Russland auch die
sogenannte teilmobilisierung weiter
wobei die Russen auch da einmal mehr die
Erfahrung machen dass den Worten ihres
Präsidenten besser nicht zu trauen ist
etwa die Ankündigung dass nur 300.000
Kampf erfahrene Russen eingezogen werden
das ist aber bleibt wird bezweifelt und
die einberufungsbefehle gehen wohl auch
keineswegs nur an Männer die militärisch
trainiert sind wie Putin sagte und so
versuchen jetzt immer mehr Russen ihr
Land zu verlassen fragt sich nur wer
bereit ist sie aufzunehmen Andrea Maurer
richtet
die Bilder ähneln sich in Georgien in
Kasachstan kilometerlange Schlangen auch
vor der EU-Außengrenze nach Finnland
Russen fliehen vor Putins
ich habe Angst davor eingezogen zu
werden ich möchte nicht an diesem Krieg
teilnehmen deshalb habe ich mich zur
Flucht entschieden escape die
Bundesregierung zeigt sich offen
Kriegsdienst Verweigerer aufzunehmen
natürlich zeichnet sich auch ab dass es
eine Fluchtbewegung aus Russland geben
kann
in Richtung Westen in Richtung Europa
viele Russen die nun einberufen werden
wollen sich auch nicht an diesem Krieg
beteiligen auch das ist erstmal ein
gutes Zeichen russische Deserteure
können in Deutschland Asyl als politisch
Verfolgte beantragen hat die
Innenministerin erklärt unter der
Prämisse dass man sich immer noch den
Einzelfall anschauen muss und auch eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung vornehmen muss
weil wir natürlich auch gerade aus
Russland
immer Sicherheitserwägungen nicht
vergessen dürfen und uns anschauen
müssen gerade auch aus dem russischen
Militär wer kommt da nach Deutschland
humanitäre Korridore fordert nun der
russischstämmige europaabgeordne sehr
gutinski allerdings nur für Dissidenten
nicht für
deserteuredenten können wir ganz klar
sagen dass sie diesen Krieg und dieses
Regime ablehnen und ich finde dass wir
die humanitäre Kanäle die wir jetzt
haben für diese Menschen
schwerpunktmäßig ausweiten sollten
anstatt jetzt versprechen zu machen für
alle die potenziell eingezogen werden
der Fluchtweg in die EU wird unterdessen
schwieriger Estland Lettland Litauen und
Polen weisen schon seit Tagen Russen ab
auch Finnland erwägt
einreisebeschränkungen die
Bundesregierung strebt nun eine
gemeinsame europäische Linie an wie mit
denen umgegangen werden soll die in
Putins Krieg nicht kämpfen wollen
das Diktatur und vor allem vor ihrem
eigenen Volk Angst haben lässt sich
derzeit ja auch wieder in Iran
beobachten nachdem das müller-regime
landesweit das Internet eingeschränkt
hat ist es schwieriger an Informationen
und Bilder zu kommen unser Korrespondent
Jörg Brase hat heute in Teheran noch
gefilmt bevor er ausgereist ist hier
sein Bericht
sie wollen bewahren was andere seit
Tagen bekämpfen das
religiös-konservative Regime hatte seine
Getreuen zu Tausenden auf die Straße
gerufen wir sind bereit für unseren
obersten Führer unser Leben zu geben
schwören sie entschlossen das System und
dessen Regeln zu verteidigen und dazu
zählt auch dass die Frau sich bedeckt
hält
[Musik]
Vertrauen in unsere Gesetze und die
islamische Scharia und wir müssen uns
darauf konzentrieren dass diese Gesetze
auch eingehalten werden
und nun sollten wissen dass dies ein
islamisches Land ist und wer hier leben
will sollte sich an die Regeln dieses
Landes halten
drinnen beim Freitagsgebet wettert Ahmad
ratami Mitglied des hohen Wächterrates
der todmasse aminis sei zu betrauern
sagt er doch was ich seit Tagen auf den
Straßen abspiele sei ein Krieg gegen die
islamische Republik zusammen es geht
ihnen darum unsere Religion anzugreifen
es geht ihnen darum den Koran zu
verbrennen und Moscheen anzuzünden und
darum das muslimische Kopftuch
abzuschaffen
[Musik]
Irans Führung fühlt sich angegriffen und
schlägt zurück die wütenden Proteste
gegen den Kopftuch Zwang schlagen viele
Orts um in den Kampf gegen das
eiertoller Regime der sei vom Ausland
organisiert und gesteuert heißt es der
Präsident sendet aus dem fernen New York
die Botschaft friedlicher Protest ja
Chaos aber werde nicht länger geduldet
wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
Demonstrationen und Vandalismus
Demonstrationen sind gut denn dadurch
können Menschen ihre Meinung ausdrücken
über bestimmte Dinge die Sie
voranbringen wollen
der Geheimdienst waren das Volk nicht
mehr an verbotenen Versammlungen
teilzunehmen die Staatsmacht scheint zu
allem entschlossen es drohen dunkle Tage
mit vielen Opfern
jetzt gehen wir nach Deutschland und zu
Heinz Wolf weltweit haben sich heute
zahlreiche Menschen am 11 globalen
klimastreik von Fridays for future
beteiligt allein in Deutschland gingen
laut den Organisatoren insgesamt rund
280.000 Menschen auf die Straße unter
dem Motto Menschen statt Profite eine
zentrale Forderung der Bewegung ist ein
staatliches Sondervermögen für
Klimaschutz in Höhe von 100 Milliarden
Euro
mit Blick auf einen milliarden-loch bei
den gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung hat
der Bundestag einen Gesetzentwurf zur
finanziellen Stabilisierung auf den Weg
gebracht
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
Versicherte es bleibe bei dem
Grundprinzip dass man keine
Leistungskürzungen wolle Teil des
geplanten finanzpaketes ist eine
Anhebung des Zusatzbeitrags um 0,3%
Punkte getragen je zur Hälfte von
Arbeitgebern und Versicherten
das Wohngeld für Haushalte mit wenig
Einkommen soll im Zuge der vom Bund
geplanten Reform offenbar deutlich
steigen um durchschnittlich 190 Euro auf
rund 370 Euro pro Monat das geht nach
Medienberichten also an einem Entwurf
von bauministerin gaiwitz hervor
außerdem wird der Kreis der Berechtigten
deutlich ausgeweitet
und die Wetteraussichten morgen im Osten
und der Mitte freundliche Abschnitte
sonst viele Wolken und zeitweise etwas
Regen im Südwesten einzelne Gewitter
Höchstwerte 14 bis 20 Grad am Sonntag
bei 14 bis 19 Grad vor allem im Westen
und Süden Schauer sonst auch länger
freundlich in der neuen Woche nass kühl
und sehr windig
das war es auch schon von uns in diesem
schnellen halbzeitjournal und unser
heute journal Update gibt es dann um
0.20 mit Nazan gökdemir wiedersehen
[Musik]